ich bin jung ich bin naiv und ich suche
das risiko für sie gerichte ein wo es
richtig gefährlich ist es ist kann dem i
und ich fahre jetzt pnv oliva los
volle busse und bahnen pendeln ohne
abstand doch einer kann mich im op en v
hygienisch an die hand nehmen
professor klaus dieter zastrow
deutschlands hygiene papst für den
mieten wir sogar einen eigenen bus kommt
rein
die werden jetzt einzeln zur verfügung
gestellt sind sie schon am flirten an
der bushaltestelle gefragt was er für
busses da habe ich hier erklärt dass sie
jetzt für jeden einzelnen kommen
wie oft haben sie öffentliche
verkehrsmittel gar nicht weil sie halt
gesund bleiben wollen
ich kenne die gefahren und dann sah ich
will gehe ich lieber in einer
einzelzelle und bleibt da drin dann aber
neben man braucht auch ein bisschen hirn
und papst zu werden so ist es also wenn
man das nicht hat überlebt man ja auch
nicht also was ist jetzt an die pendler
die jeden morgen bus und bahn fahren
auto kaufen der papst steht ja genug
geld zu haben alle anderen müssen
pendeln am berliner ostkreuz treffe ich
auf das gemeine volk freuen sie sich
sehr auf s bahn fahren heute ungemein
ja ja macht richtig bock und corona zeit
aber total ja ja so richtig schön auf
einer skala von 1 bis 10 -12 wenn man
fahren muss dann fährt man das spielt
doch keine rolle
ich nehme an sie sind jetzt direkt auf
dem weg ins home office direktor im home
office zu einem termin ja und dann
wieder zu office zu fahren auch mit der
erst mal nicht mehr freiberufliche zwei
super special events an einem tag hinweg
rückweg richtig
wie schaffen wir es die pendelei sicher
und corona konform zu gestalten also das
sicherste verfahren ist und das habe ich
der politik sei 100 mal geschrieben
erzählt frau merkel hat nicht von mir
kriegt einsparen indem man den ort des
entstehens desinfiziert mit einem
schleimhaut desinfektionsmittel nicht
mit kochsalzlösung holen oder sowas
wenn hier keine viren mehr sind oder
nicht genügend sind dann sind wir safe
und das haben die politiker bis heute
nicht kapiert welche auszeichnungen
gefällt ihnen besser tragischer held der
arbeit oder tragende säule der pandemie
tragende säule japan vielleicht ja da
kann man sagen ja ich habe heute wieder
was geschafft für das virus für das land
haben sie angst vor corona sind sie
schon den vollen bahnen auch gefahren
nein nein sie nehmen nur die leeren
waren ja ich habe heute dabei sein wird
es kalt wird
ich habe auch ein paar ideen für hygiene
konzepte und wer wenn nicht der hygiene
papst kann mir dafür seinen segen geben
wir sind ja eben diese rote hämmerchen
die mich jetzt natürlich nicht anfassen
aber ich habe mir überlegt scheibe
einschlagen wird durch zum frischluft
wunderbare zukunft sagen wir
regelmäßiges lüften
also das ist sehr wohl geeignet die
viren abzutransportieren
gute idee herr fahrer dürfte ich eine
scheibe einschlagen wenn es frisch und
willens kanzlei hof würden sie mich
mitnehmen mit ihrem auto wenn nicht
ausgeschlossen werden auf gar keinen
fall aus infektions geschädigt da wir
kein selbstmörder
mein nächstes hygiene konzept jeder
bringt ein eigenes seil mit um die
griffe nicht anfassen zu müssen wenn man
versehentlich im kopf dadurch steckt
dann hilft das natürlich auch denn wer
da drin hängt er kann auch nicht mehr an
steckt also jetzt haben sie weniger
angst vor mir als vorher genau weil weil
viel wird aus ihrem hals nicht mehr
rauskommen und wenn man auf nummer
sicher gehen will dann lässt man sich
natürlich außen an den bus anbinden was
sind ihre worte an die verantwortlichen
vom öpnv mehr züge einsetzen
sagen sie das nicht mehr sagen sie dass
im öpnv die pnv liebe bvg liebe deutsche
bahn setzt einfach mehr züge ein
macht eine größere taktung setzt mehr
busse einsetzen der strapazen baden ein
vielen dank dafür ruft man ein
ultimatives millionen konzept also das
sieht sehr solide aus da kann ich im
moment auch nichts dran entdecken wo
sich viren noch vorbei mogeln könnten
das sieht sehr zuverlässig aus ja
hurra ich habe den hygiene papst
überzeugt und ich will mich noch bei
jemandem bedanken und jetzt spenden wir
nochmal applaus für die wahren helden
der pandemie die pendler waren sie in
dieser mut und damit zurück nach köln
taxi
[Musik]
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut
los los du scheiße fährt